foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Friday November 4th I'm Julie Chang for
the Wall Street Journal filling in for
Zoe Thomas
the gaming industry is going through a
lot of changes right now growth in cloud
gaming subscriptions nfts on top of that
Microsoft announced its plan to acquire
Activision Blizzard earlier this year
though it hasn't been smooth sailing the
69 billion dollar deal caught the
attention of regulators across the world
Phil Spencer CEO of Microsoft gaming sat
down with wsj reporter Sarah needleman
at the Wall Street journal's annual Tech
live conference last week they talked
about the Activision Blizzard deal
Microsoft's battle with another Tech
Giant Apple over the iPhone Maker's
Hefty Commission on in-app purchases
Microsoft's long-term gaming Ambitions
and more here are highlights from that
conversation
so last time we talked about uh you had
just purchased zenimax the parents of
Bethesda which makes a bunch of great
games like Fallout Elder Scrolls and I
asked you at the time if you were done
on your shopping spree or if you're
still shopping around and uh looks like
you did make a a pretty big deal for
Activision Blizzard
not done yet still in regulatory
that is true uh but my question is again
are are we done shopping or could we
expect more deals for more gaming
studios in the future
well you know when we look at video
games today
in over three billion people on the
planet play video games which is just
kind of astounding nearly half the
world's population plays video games the
business itself is a 200 billion dollar
business growing by almost double digits
every year so for us at Microsoft we
look at this category and we see a
category that's in some transition where
we have some Legacy and franchises that
matter and we're going to continue to
invest I think it's something where we
see the opportunity we love the
community around our games and our
properties and our Studios and the more
we can build towards that future of more
people playing uh I think it's a it's a
good business opportunity for the
company and a good audience opportunity
when you think about the age demographic
that we attract as well okay so more
deals could be on the horizon I'll keep
my eyes peeled for that so one of the
major sticking points at least in the UK
about this deal is around Activision's
Call of Duty franchise Microsoft has
said that it plans to continue making
that franchise available on all the
different platforms yeah but you haven't
said for how long or for how much I mean
could this change at some point could a
couple years down the road you say it's
exclusive to Xbox game pass or it's
exclusive for people who want to stream
it but if you want to buy at a disk you
could play it on say PlayStation that's
not our plan our plan is that Call of
Duty specifically would be available on
PlayStations what you're asking about
but when I think about our plans I'd
love to see it on the switch I'd love to
see the game playable on many different
screens but if we Circle back to why
this deal is important to us
when you're spending the amount that
we're spending looking at the
opportunity in gaming this opportunity
is really about mobile for us and I know
as you said most of the dialogue that's
out there has been around consoles and
how Xbox and PlayStation consoles
compete with each other but when you
think about three billion people playing
video games there's only about 200
million households that play on Console
a vast majority of the people who play
play on the device that's already in
their pocket which is their phone the
thing that made us really interested in
Activision Blizzard King was the great
work that the teams there had done in
building such large mobile followings a
lot of that with the King Studio that
they have with Candy Crush which is a
big franchise a lot of people know but
also if you look at Call of Duty mobile
which to me actually in the Strategic
rationale behind this deal is more
interesting than what's happening on
Console between Xbox and Playstation
with this franchise that will continue
to ship on Playstation natively we don't
it's not a plan of okay we're gonna bait
and switch somebody where they got to
play on the cloud or that at two or
three years we're gonna pull the game
are intent is that we would continue to
ship Call of Duty on Playstation as long
as that made sense you know as long as
like Tech is always in some form of
transition but this deal for us really
centered around our opportunity to get
more mobile engagement in Xbox and the
great work that the teams had done there
one of the things that
through the edge
is that Microsoft is looking to expand
its Xbox store to mobile devices
and I'm wondering how is
how does it allow third parties to
operate stores on the iPhone and iPad so
is this a is this a fantasy how are you
gonna get around this
well it's definitely true today that the
largest gaming platform on the planet
which is mobile phone is controlled by
two companies Google and apple and not
only do they have the storefronts
whenever somebody tells you to go find
an app it's Discovery it's monetization
it's search in many ways people go to
the stores to search and we have to find
a way to create more engagement and
monetization for us in Mobile it's
imperative for our business there's no
way that you succeed as a gaming company
if you don't have access to mobile
players so how do we do that I think
it's it's multifaceted we have to break
that duopoly of only two storefronts
available on the largest platforms if
you look at Windows as an example
there's a multitude of storefronts
available on Windows and I think that
creates healthy competition we've also
invested a lot in our Cloud streaming
where we're able to today stream Xbox
games to the phone through the internet
and that works it's not native to the
phone so it's there's a little more
friction and that the platforms put in
place for us actually getting to our
customers Microsoft supported epic games
maker fortnite
battle against Apple over the app
store's 30 tax on digital sales but
while Microsoft said it's lowering the
cut that it takes on its Xbox App Store
the company continues to take three
percent on the console how come
yeah consoles as a business model one as
I said in the overall scope of gaming
it's fairly small relative to the places
that people play consoles evolved to a
business model much different than
phones where consoles are actually sold
at a loss in the market so when somebody
goes and they buy an Xbox at their local
retailer we're subsidizing that purchase
somewhere between 100 and 200 with the
expectation that we will recoup that
investment over time through accessory
sales and storefront
mobile phones are not sold at a loss
mobile phones are profitable their
general purpose Computing devices and
much more like Windows I think it should
be a platform that's open and as you
said on Windows we have reduced our
royalty because we look at Windows as a
profitable business for us and we want
it to be a place where creators and
players meet and you mentioned epic I
think it's telling that
Apple at the result of Epic raising a
complaint what did they do they threw
out the largest game in the world from
their store
how has Microsoft's conversation with
apple evolved since that lawsuit and
that trial has Apple shown any openness
at all in maybe allowing cloud gaming
uh what Apple specifically asked us to
do was to use the web browser which
we've done so if you you can use the
Safari web browser on a phone it's not
the natural place people go to find
games but it does work today and we have
fortnite available on iOS phones not an
ad but that is the way you can play on
iOS phones is through our streaming
technology on the phones but there's so
much friction going from somebody tells
you hey you should go play this game you
should go find this new app nobody
thinks to go to web browser and then
search for it so it's there's so much
work for us to do to overcome the
friction and on in Android we actually
do have an app in the store we're just
not able to monetize all right thank you
very much for coming thank you
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week we had editorial support from
Falana Patterson our supervising
producer is Chris zinsley and I'm Julie
Chang filling in for our host Zoe Thomas
thanks for listening and have a great
weekend
[Music]